in pursuit of silence is your latest
project and it's about noise and all in
pursuit of silence is about the value of
silence and properties of silence and
our relationship with sound and the
implications of living in such a noisy
environment noisy world yeah and so we
just launched a UH and you asked about
what intrigued me about it yeah you know
I don't at first I didn't really know
what intrigued me about sentence so much
it was more like you know curious about
it because I don't have an experience of
silence in my life I mean I live in Los
Angeles or close to Los Angeles and I
live in a very noisy environment and it
was like what is so great about silence
and why I have people throughout the
ages sought silence so passionately you
know you know everything from you know
monastics to you know the moment of
silence that has sort of evolved over
time as a sort of secular way of kind of
honoring the dead and you know what is
it about silence that's so meaningful
and so that kind of just kind of drove
me to want to know more about silence
and then I saw this movie called
integrate silence I think it's back in
two thousand six I was a documentary
about these monks that what are they
called chartreuse no I better not even
attempted I forget what they're called
but it was about monks who have taken
this vow of silence and I think they get
an hour if I remember correctly an hour
a week to actually speak to one another
but aside from that it's strictly just
kind of doing the work in silence and
chanting and whatnot and that really got
me into silence and I was kind of
intrigued by these monks relationship
with silence and then I read about the
work of John Cage who was an American
composer who was really big on silence
he's famous for doing for composing this
piece called four minutes and 33 seconds
during which you know the performer sits
and does nothing for four minutes and 33
seconds and symphonies and orchestras
around the world will actually compose
this piece in the middle of their the
repertoire you know their concerts and
it's pretty pretty amazing stuff it
really kind of forces people to confront
silent
and how they sort of interpret a space
and and it's it's it's cool it's
mysterious and it's powerful its elusive
and there's just something really
intriguing about it for me and then I
stumbled upon noise and all these
studies have been done about noise and
how damaging it is to our health and you
know if you know our health or mental
health or physical health all across the
board it's not just that this annoyance
you know i think i read recently that
the World Health Organization is
basically refers to the noise pollution
as like the second most damaging a
threat to our health second to nopa air
pollution so it's like become this very
very big problem in industrialized parts
of the world and so just yes naturally
this idea of doing silence and noise and
a documentary kind of dawned on me and I
got really excited yeah are you extra
sensitive to noise does it affect you to
be in a chaotic tomorrow you know I
think it does yeah and I have two young
children at home to now and so you know
when I walk into my house it's just like
this wall of noise you know like my kids
aren't crazy or anything the pretty
mellow kids but it's there's like this
wall of noise that I walk into each and
every day when I go home and you know I
think it wasn't until I started reading
into noise and silence and thinking
about this documentary that I realized
how it really is affecting me and how
knowing it really is and how you know
stressful it makes me some of the
studies about noise clearly show that
even though that we're able to tune out
noise psychologically speaking our
bodies can't and so it's still affecting
us on like you know stress level all the
stress markers are going up so every
time of plane flies overhead for example
like we just kind of have habituated it
you know like it's just part of the
background but our bodies are reacting
to all these noises that are happening
around us in a negative way and so yeah
and I think I've become sensitive to
noise
for sure
you